but in the same way our Visions Inspire
us they can also start to limit us
if we hear the same narratives over and
over again and if we see the same
visuals over and over again
then that becomes our scope of
possibility that becomes our Benchmark
for what we believe is good
and what's not talk to your grandmother
ask her how she imagines the future and
I bet you she'll tell you that no one
asks her that anymore
or read that Filipino science fiction
novel watch a Nigerian post-apocalyptic
film look for stories that ask what if
from A New Perspective when we choose to
be curious about the Alternatives and
when we take them seriously
will start to think in new ways we'll
solve problems in new ways and we'll
just start to see possibilities that we
couldn't see before